major announcement from Amazon Amazon
has announced that it is going to be
opening a grocery store in Seattle
Washington early in 2017 what is notable
about this grocery store well it's not
going to have any cashiers in fact it's
going to need very very few employees
because the way it's going to work is
when you walk in you will scan your
phone which will tell the store that
you're inside and then they will have a
very sophisticated system that uses
sensors computer vision deep learning
which will track customers as they move
through the store and it will register
what items you pick up and put in your
basket you'd change your mind and put an
item back on the shelves the system will
be able to determine that as well
there's going to be prepared food salad
sandwiches etcetera that will all be
handmade but it will be sold in boxes
that are also part of the entire
automated system and then when you're
done you just walk out of the store
because the system tracks what you have
in your basket there's no need to check
out it'll just automatically be billed
to your credit card on file
so obviously Amazon is talking about
this as total utopia uh it's gonna cut
down on lines it's going to cut down on
a lot of the stuff that's annoying about
going grocery shopping particularly in
urban areas but there's the other side
of this which is this would be a major
job killer if you think about the 3.4
million people who were employed as
cashiers in the United States according
to the US Labor Bureau of Labor
Statistics and if you think about the
4.5 million employed as retail
salespeople and the 2.4 million
employees laborers that are stocking
shelves and moving cargo around Amazon
is automating away many of these jobs
they already have robots in warehouses
to move cargo around they have new
robots that are able to not only find
items on shelves but also prepare items
for shipment this is something that I
truly believe pat is inevitable when we
look at the advance of Technology and
you go to a grocery store and you see a
cashier scanning items one by one and
punching in produce uh stock codes
that does not strike me as something
that is remotely necessary five or ten
years down the line given all of the
technological developments that we have
why are we going to need cashiers to
scan your items in many stores already
putting in in place itself uh self
checkouts uh but I I don't believe that
pushing back against this because it's
going to be a job killer is going to be
effective because when you just look at
what the job is and what technology can
do how do you justify millions of
cashiers just ringing products through a
scanner right it seems like cashiers
will be the next victim of automation
and technology but it's overall a good
thing I mean scribes were upset hundreds
of years ago in the printing press came
out I have a friend who won't use self
checkouts because he doesn't want to
encourage stores to put in self
checkouts it's a very nice gesture but
it is going to do nothing to stop this
and the broader analysis here is we had
a very drawn-out presidential election
campaign with tons of discussion about
bringing jobs back and manufacturing
jobs etcetera etcetera no serious
discussion of the fact that many of the
jobs Trump wants to bring back no longer
exists and the more important discussion
that jobs are going to be destroyed by
technology up I don't believe that
pushing back about against this is going
to be effective whether it's Amazon or
someone else if you really just think
about where technology is right now and
then you think about lots of the jobs
that still exist it's very hard to
justify those jobs still existing 510 or
at the most fifteen years down the line